économie environnement énergie au social
et
le développement durable à la réunion
c'est maintenant c'est benoît nous
sommes dans un dépôt collège et on veut
limiter le gaspillage d'eau on a
remarqué un gaspillage d'eau près du
réfectoire
on a donc demandé aux agents de change
et robin abîmée de réparer le robinet
ont des fuites place de physique on a
mesuré la quantité 2 qui s'est coulé des
robinets
quand on appuie une seule fois il y
avait trois litres d'eau qui s'écoule et
alors on a observé le comportement de
certains élèves certains appuyer une
seule fois mais garder la main appuyée
et d'autres a tué plusieurs fois et sans
donner on a on a remarqué qu'il y avait
un réel gaspillage les éco gestes pour
économiser l'eau sont changés les
robinets abîmé et réparer les roubines
ayant 18 informer les élèves pour mieux
utiliser les robinets une seule fois
appuyé une seule fois suffit pour se
laver les mains ou boire de l'eau
économisez jusqu'à 130 euros sur mes
factures d'eau comment je prends une
douche plutôt qu'un bain j'ai fermement
robinet eu le temps de me laver les
mains les dents ou en me rasant je
n'utilise le lave vaisselle et le lave
linge que s'ils sont pleins je choisis 8
shasdo économique je récupère les eaux
de pluie pour effectuer des tâches comme
le nettoyage ou l'arrosage du jardin qui
arrosent les jardins pendant les heures
les plus fraîches de la journée c'est à
dire tous le matin ou à la tombée de la
nuit je lave mon véhicule une fois par
mois à la maison ou dans une station
service et non dans la ravine
alors vous voyez préserver
l'environnement c'est augmenter notre
pouvoir d'achat
le conseil général agit pour le
développement durable et vous économie
environnement énergie au social
bien
le développement durable à la réunion
c'est maintenant